[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
oh [ __ ] here we go hey I have a walk-in
to clean I've been here I want to go get
that cleaning because it's number one
right now is it soon this is joke just a
joke
they're partying and I'm upset and we're
just upsetting everything that's going
on and I want it this is I'm just upset
thank you for two minutes I'm gonna go
walking just walk off like that clean
the walkers you know why why do I feel
like a [ __ ] jerk because I'm upset I
was [ __ ] unacceptable and Arizona
accepts if a [ __ ] walk in with a
[ __ ] black mole why don't you do
something about it
is that normal
what I witnessed tonight this Philip
always here dispel it always expedite
the [ __ ] hot plate no no we need
somebody to expedite we're understaffed
and if we get busy then we can't give
good service and those people will not
come back a person can't shortcut like
dad this place the business been
strangled yeah it's been strangled by
the owner why are we pretending I'm
doing a good job of pretending then this
is what I do every time that you come in
here this is what you do I do not run
food down to your bar for the last
couple nights
let's talk about the elephant in the
room shall we
when Philips drinking he behaves one or
two different ways either he's jovial
and likes to giggle and have a good time
or if finances are in arrears and we
hear about how much everything costs you
and you were gonna close the doors it's
stressful it's not easy to come to work
with someone but threatening us all the
time that the doors are gonna be closed
please don't look at me like that Philip
because you do do this to us that's
[ __ ]
you need the truth you have told us over
and over and over again that you're just
gonna show me I may have said that twice
twice come in here regularly and say I'm
gonna close the doors
if we keep lying about [ __ ] and we keep
covering up [ __ ] and whatever then he
ain't gonna [ __ ] help us and here we
go like this like we've been going for
seven [ __ ] years he's he's been known
to walk behind the bar and fix himself
drinks after the staff cuts more food
yes essentially that I don't know about
that I don't know about I've gone by the
board made my own drinks yes so you
blacked out your that and he berated
that you've got no [ __ ] idea that
you're that far gone he goes behind the
bar take the drink away from him he can
not go to see you in there in the first
place why is he even in that bar in the
first place why is it why that to me
it's hypocritical you put out memo
saying that we can't drink in the bar
it's hypocritical Philip and we care
about this place and we care about you
[Music]
I've been told that tonight the
Roosevelt in is holding a murder mystery
dinner is an event they host once a
month I have a feeling it's gonna be
hard to forget
if you're head on into there I'll get
you all checked in when you go you're
fabulous we usually always have a lot of
fun with this we're going to continue
and have fun with this are you dressing
them this evening I play the part of
Sherlock Holmes that you're playing an
Englishman I am playing an Englishman
and I even heard the pipe to go with it
I've studied this I sent long and hard
in fact wine is better than a magician
[Music]
slightly weird I wonder if this event
even makes any money is this profitable
it is profitable yeah it's a lot of work
I mean we made $200 tonight
$200 for always were stained Oh No
what's the locals you know when they
come from under mister they usually
don't do it overnight oh well that could
explain it I say sit down
nice fish asses I'm tired I bet you are
stick a fork in me Matt was it mad yeah
you're in the kitchen busting your
ourselves working hard to sell all those
people and John you about prancing
around like a sort of actor that the
thespian thing isn't in it's not a
theater but you seem to enjoy it you
have to force yourself to like doing it
when it's on stage for three hours
[Music]
the problem that the roosevelt
elementary class the over the owner I'm
sure this place is sinking because John
refuses to take anything seriously you
love being an entertainer don't you dare
tell me that that is hardly this whole
[ __ ] thing was put together for your
fantasy well that's kind of what this
night is it is entertainment we put on a
show you're pretending to be Sherlock
Holmes and upstairs we're empty during
the sheet financially we're in ruins and
if you put the same amount of effort
into filling this place just one room
booked tonight would have made more
profit than the whole murder mystery and
all that work that went into it this is
insane and you prance around like some
[ __ ] idiot while your wife is slaving
away in the kitchen
chillie care in the world apart for
yourself when you get a psychology
degree oh well I don't you come and tell
me what's wrong with me here we go you
obviously think you are psychologist
denial again no I'm not in denial I just
don't know what you want it's only your
own [ __ ] stupidity to why we're in
the [ __ ] this far well that is probably
true so then man up and act responsible
now you don't need me here to tell you
the soup is that disgusting that even
before anybody tasting it it smells
burnt this is where we make our own food
unbelievable have you given up young
lady do you hate food what's going on
they used to love my job and then now I
hate it I can see what's not working for
you any honors I'm not gonna tolerate
disrespect you know we're not getting
paid we're not paying ourselves honest
owners complain about not being paper
you [ __ ] owe your place
they don't have ownership of this
historic building hey daddy's not paying
for everything can I tell you something
Gordon jen has called herself the best
cook in town she's just all that picking
on her you have turned every [ __ ]
member of staff against you
I used to be really chirpy and happy and
I
I can't even smile anymore it's not
about you I don't even
motivate myself to do my pride again
just listen to both of you you're only
as good as a tomb underneath you whether
you were here three months a [ __ ]
year or three hours a day it doesn't
matter yeah you had to what I had to
wait five weeks before I got a paycheck
five weeks guys you come in and you work
your ass off the least these two guys
can do is pay your [ __ ] salary on
time I don't have a secretary Gordon I'm
sorry I'm trying to communicate with
brides I'm trying to send out things I
have to have peaceful time in order to
do my work are you always this pathetic
I am NOT pathetic well when are you
gonna stand up and start showing some
respect for your team and start growing
a pair to sort of understand the mess
you're in I understand the mess we're in
crime fighting for the team
you dug the [ __ ] hole yes I'm put a
minute so there [ __ ] they don't have to
work here
oh my me you know the bottom line how
dare you know they don't have to work
here how dare you how [ __ ] dare you
they don't have to work here oh my god I
get disrespectful disgusting man
they don't have to work here I don't
think you realize how [ __ ] lucky you
are there's not all about you Robert
Roberts world rubbers bubble Roberts
dream
you're not the lord of the manor and
you're not the Great Gatsby you all
you're Robert it's only me in here
excuse me excuse me
go on then you pompous [ __ ] excuse me
don't talk to me much what what's wrong
with it I want to know what don't speak
to me like I'm telling you you head out
your ass and start getting a little
[ __ ] real you still haven't got it
that this place is sinking start paying
a little bit more attention to the guys
on the ground
understand how hard it is out there
forget your [ __ ] antique road show
and start from the bottom running this
business you're right there's no
structure it's fragmented the team needs
a leader they need a structure
I need a mentor I need some support and
all they get is nitpicked what kind of
motivation is that all right Hertz's
have been here you're just blaming
people
well I'm blaming you for not taking
charge get [ __ ] real